hallo willkommen zu vlogmas Tag
4 korrekt boah krass schon vierter Tag
ey schon vierten Tag durchgezogen Leute
das klappt ich find es auch richtig gut
wie die alle mal schreiben und schon
raten wie lange ich vlogm dieses Jahr
durchziehen kann ich glaube ich ziehe
vlogmas dieses Jahr komplett durch das
Ding ist ich habe nämlich endlich Timo
der mir hilft der will sonst immer nicht
für mich arbeiten könnt ihr euch das
vorstellen ist nicht so wie bei Sally
und Mura dass sie
zusammen
vielleicht ist es gut dass wir nicht
zusammenarbeiten vielleicht sollten wir
eigentlich mein Tanzbereich dein
Tanzbereich morgen geht es nach
Mailand morgen geht unsere riesenreise
los wir waren noch nie im Dezember weg
ich meine Urlaub ist es jetzt auch nicht
wirklich weil wir ja halt jeden Tag
drehen würdest du es als Urlaub
bezeichnen eigentlich habe ich gesagt
schon aber jetzt nachdem ich wie ich
gemerkt habe wie die ersten Tage
ablaufen nicht mehr
nee das so übelst entspannend ist zu
schneiden aber einfach 5 Stunden für den
VOG gebraucht ja direkt die Kamera in
die Hand gen nichts gegessen nicht
gefrühstückt mich eigentlich wie de ein
dier ja ich habe aber Thema
Frühstück ich habe dir was
besorgt hast jetzt wieder Energie kannst
jetzt perfekt während du stundenlang
geschnitten hast habe ich mich nach
draußen in die kilte begeben und hab
geholt Advent Liebe
Kind wow die ist sehr intens unser
blumenmann ist halt Vietnamese und ich
lieb es das in allen vietnamesischen
Läden ob das ein Supermarkt bei uns ist
oder halt ein Blumengeschäft die haben
immer vorne so ein Tempel ich muss mich
da mal rein Fuchsen was das warum da
immer so ein Tempel ist oder so ein
Schrein so ein das ein Obst und
dannimmer so Räucherstäbchen ich denke
mal das ist für gut g luck also wenn ihr
vietnamesisch seid oder wisst was es ist
dann schreibt gerne ja und das ist jetzt
unser Advent z ist ein kleiner ich meine
wir sind nicht viel da Dezember das ist
ein kleiner süßer das machen wir so gibt
irgendwie ein Ritual noch was man am
ersten Advent macht Kerze anzünden
Check und jetzt zeige ich euch mein
Adventskalender ja ja ja wür ich schon
sagen ja W wir schon sag komm komm mit
und vielleicht ach nee Hassan schläft
egal stimmt Leute hier schon mal ein
kleiner Sneak peeak
Hamstergehege
toll okay um den geht's jetzt aber
erstmal nicht ich habe dieses Jahr
mehrere Adventskalender und die Leute
fragen mich immer Vanessa du packst so
viele Adventskalender aus welchen
Adventskalender hast du denn für dich
persönlich und ich habe mir ehrlich
gesagt nur einen dieses Jahr besorgt und
zwar den von
ikear weil ich immer diese
Geschenkgutscheine gut finde und man
kann hier was gewinnen und weil wir
umziehen und neue Sachen brauchen werden
dachte ich so komm ich wollte erstmal
fünf mitnehmen und dann hat es mir
verboten weil er gesagt hat das ist as
ich we ich kann noch nicht dahinterkmen
was daran asi ist ich find es nicht asi
ich fand es gut das ist timus den er mir
geschenkt hat das ist ein
Veganer ja Kalender damit ich die
Schokolade auch essen kann Türchen
Nummer
3 und hier ist jeden Tag so ein Tropfen
drin bisschen traurig aber schmeckt
nach se 12 Sindy se 12 sind creamy shock
m ne der ist wirklich sehr lecker kann
ich empfehlen dann hatte ich noch einen
Kalender von Kels übrig da machen wir
auch mal tüchen Nummer 3 auf hier sind
halt so kleine Proben drin von Produkten
oh die kenne ich glaube ich sogar oh ja
die kenne ich die riecht sehr gut das
ist die Calendula Serum infused watercam
ganz wichtig aber es sind super kleine
Produkte also Kel ist halt mega teuer
deswegen ja ist es wahrscheinlich
Preisleistung am Ende passend aber ja
den MA ich auch mal auf hab wir gar
nicht aufgemacht Moment Ikea macht das
in Kooperation mit so einem
pralinhersteller mit hes hes Gonzales
das finde ich halt mega cool weil der am
Ende mit diesen Gutschein kostet der
Kalender halt 2,99 und dafür halt so
viele
pralin aber von den kriege ich halose
also gut da ist der von Timo besser oh
geh ist mit Alkohol und dann habe ich
noch einen Kalender zugeschickt bekommen
bücherbox ich kann mich nicht erinnern
bücherbox okay ja dieser Kalender hier
das sieht aus als ob du den gebastelt
hast aber den habe ich von bücherbox
heißen die glaube ich ich blende noch
mal ein wie die in Wirklichkeit heißen
und die haben mir einen zugeschickt
damit ich ihn vielleicht in ein Video
teste das habe ich aber auch nicht mehr
geschafft zeitlich deswegen dachte ich
hey ich bin eine kleine Leseratte
irgendwo tief ganz tief drin versteckt
und hatte ich jetzt schon ein Türchen
aufgemacht da war ein Buch drin feels
like Christmas also Bücher mit Thema
Weihnachten finde ich auch eigentlich
ganz spannend werde ich definitiv lesen
wenn wir jetzt unterwegs sind gestern
war da so ein Holzschwert drin was
glaube ich ein Lesezeichen ist oder so
Türchen Nummer 3 sieht gut
aus boah ist das ein dicker Schinken
guck mal wie das hier auch schon wieder
siehst du das a dark and hollow Star
nichts ist gefährlicher als ein Märchen
von Ashley Shuttleworth seit
Jahrhunderten leben die ach Höfe des
feenvolkes mitten unter uns verborgen
durch Magie an und das Gesetz gebunden
den Menschen ich le erstmal lesen l
bücherkalender cool eigentlich ne ja so
Fantasy Bücher habe mich irgendwie nie
rangetraut weil si halt immer aus nach
Final Fantasy irgendwas also gerade
dieses Cover sieht nach Final Fantasy
aus und ein Kalender habe ich auch noch
kommt
mit
das hier ist auch einer meiner
lieblingskalender da macht man einfach
nur jeden Tag die Kerze
an und dann brennt sie runter guck ich
habe sie letzt gestern habe ich sie ganz
brav bis DAH brennen lassen und jetzt
dürfen wir sie bis hierhin brennen gut
hat auch irgendwie was ne für die ganz
minimalistischen so und jetzt ist Timo
dran der darf oh wo muss ich das halten
hier kommen wir zu meinem ausgefallenen
Kalender ich habe nur einen wie normaler
Mensch so wir sind bei Nummer D ne ich
denke viele von euch kennen das System
das ist ein wirklich ganz klassischer t
oha aber mit Spruch ne glück entsteht
oft durch aufmerksam kin Ding Lück oft
durch die Vernachlässigung kleiner
Dinge ich habe nicht verstanden ich auch
nicht geil was hast du sal
Caramel
wie stell dich mal nach dahin das ist
der Shit Alter wie hat der
geschmeckt gerade noch wie
schmecktul von gestern wir sind mus nur
geknastet W
hier
umzuziehen ja mehr kann ich euch nicht
bieten Leute ah doch guck mal das der
richtig geiltig geil ja nice der
Kalender ist von deiner Mama ja ist aber
schön ne mich triggert einfach dass
er wenn wir umgezogen sind werde ich
vermissen dass dieser kühch so oft auf
geht du kannst mich berühren ohne mich
anzufassen ohne mich
anzufassen du kannst mich berühren das
einfach ein Zitat Timo und Vanessa jetzt
überlegt jeder für sich wie der die
andere das umsetzen könnte macht euch
gerne Notizen und sammelt ein paar Ideen
tauscht euch danach dazu aus welche
Gesten Worte Handlung bedeuten die etwas
bewegen zeigen dir dass du anderen
wichtig
bist ja gib Tipp KIG
König W sehr berührt Timo berühre ich
wirklich am meisten wenn ich im
Königsberger Klopse wenn du mir Essen
kochst apropos Essen kochen gute
Überleitung jetzt kommen wir nämlich
schon zum nächsten Programm Punkt Kinder
dieser Blog wird was ganz besonderes wir
haben natürlich einiges für euch
vorbereitet und müssen nicht heute
einfach nur packen um morgen zu reisen
da da ist ein pottpurri an Spaß heute
mit dabei apropos kochen wir haben ein
Kühlschrank mit Lebensmitteln und wir
sind für 10 Tage weg das heißt wir holen
jetzt mal alles raus und gucken bisschen
challengemäßig was wir damit kochen
können aber Film nicht in den
Kühlschrank das ist sehr privat erinnert
ihr euch noch an die Kinder von früher
die einfach an die Kühlschränke von
anderen Familien gegangen sind meine
Eltern fanden das immer so absurd dass
es Freunde von mir gab die einfach an
den Kühlschrank gegangen sind und das
war bei uns auch ganz auf Thema hattet
ihr Freunde die ja klar auf jeden Fall
aber die waren dann wie Familie ja aber
gehen die dann bei dir anni doch
bestimmt auch bei Anni gehe ich jetzt
als Erwachsene vorsichtig an den
Kühlschrank das auch also ich habe das
immer gemacht wenn die Eltern halt nicht
da waren also wenn Eltern nicht da war
dann habe ich mich da benommen als ob es
mein perace wä stimmt ja ich weiß es
nicht aber ja ja aber es gab so Kinder
die sind einfach so neben den Eltern so
an den Kühlschrank gegangen haben so was
gehabt ihr B schon auf jeden Fall
shoutout an Max wir haben noch seine
Nudeln okay wir haben noch Pesto Eier
die müssen wir auf jeden Fall auch
verbrauchen jooghurt zwei Tomaten eine
Paprika Lauchzwiebeln bind
gerade
Apfelrotkohl
na hast du schon eine Idee was wir
kochen können so also ich sehe hier auf
jeden Fall schon mal ein
Omelett mit Tomate wollen ein Chat GPT
schreiben wir haben auf jeden Fall wie
viel Eier sind das oder haben wir noch
ne kartoffeln haben wir nicht mehr ne
doch doch ich weiß was wir machen oh
guck mal wie die müssen wir auch noch
essen wie heißt das dieses spanische
tortia Patatas Bravas Patatas Bravas ne
keine
Ahnung das heißt Tora und man best
stellt und denkt im H sortier ist doch
dieser Chip und das ist aber so anders
du weißt nicht was ich meine wei ich
gerade nicht das ist perfekt dafüren wir
Kartoffeln und Eier oder wahrscheinlich
einfach Bratkartoffeln nein nein nein
nein das ist wie so ein auflau wie so
ein Dings dann hast du so ein wie so ein
Pizzastück wie so eine KIS die aus
Rührei und Kartoffeln drin besteht bin
nicht so richtig weiß nicht richtig was
du meinst aber ich bin auf jeden Fall
bei dir es klingt sehr
geil ja das meine ich spanische tortier
so sieht das aus traditionelle spanische
tortier guck mal und wie viel Eier
braucht man dafür vier Eier D machen wir
einfach die doppelte ja ja guck mal wir
haben acht Eier und ein Kilo Kartoffeln
und Olivenöl und Salz mir braucht man
nicht das ist unser gerecht und dann
machen wir noch ein bisschen Gemüse
jetzt erlebt ihr mich ja mal ganz privat
und privat setze ich mir immer eine
wicap drauf weil ich möchte natürlich
nicht dass Timo me meine Haare in seinem
Essen hat wie das aussieht W du das
überhaupt her husbend ich koche dir
etwas kannst du mal umdrehen ich will
auch wissen wie es aussieht
okay Mensa essen bitte das Rezept ist
wirklich das einfachste was ich jemals
gelesen habe und was ich noch nicht
gezeigt hatte weil ich nicht wusste was
wir mit den Zwiebeln machen sollen rezep
bra man auch Zwiebeln das ist wirklich
die drei Zutaten die man für dieses
Gericht braucht wo ist unser Schäler
zwar haben wir keinen Schäler aber
kitchen Queen vanessa ist wieder
da dieses Gerät ist super einfach
Kartoffeln schälen in Würfeln schneiden
anbraten Zwiebeln feinhacken anbraten
und dann alles zusammen mit Eiern in
einer Pfanne brutzeln und dann kann man
es auch einmal Ofen packen damit das
oben auch noch mal schön fest wird und
man kann es kalt und warm genießen ist
das nicht fantastisch hörast du die
Waschmaschine im Hintergrund heute ist
so ein
richtig
AUA B einfach zu groß für diese Welt
heute so ein richtiger
Dong willkommen bei der tagesshow man
hört die Waschmaschine im Hintergrund
laufen weil wir fahren ja morgen weg
eigentlich wäscht man ja seine Wäsche
sehr viel früher damit man dann frische
Wäsche hat wir sind Team wir waschen Sie
einen Tag vorher nimmen nasse Wäsche mit
und hoffen dass Sie während der Reise
irgendwann mal trocken wird nasse Wäsche
mit na ja nicht nass aber wenn wir sie
heute noch aufhängen dann wird sie
morgen früh wenn wir sie dann noch
reinschmeißen in die Koffer dann wird
das halt so klammen und was macht man
auch bevor man auf Reisen geht wir
packen den Koffer von Hassan denn der
kommt mit also Leute ich brauche ein oh
das hätte ich mal hier alles hübsch
machen können die Hamster Community ist
hart lass m einfach noch den Hamster
Käfig abfilmen der ist doch jetzt voll
hässlich er war einmal noch kurz so und
bevor ich hier irgendwie noch weiter mit
dem Hamster mache ich erzähle euch warum
ich überhaupt ein Hamster habe ich hatte
dieses Jahr meinen 30 Geburtstag und
meine Schwester kam mit einem Hamster um
die Ecke und bevor ihr jetzt sagt man
schenkt keine Tiere dieses Tier hat
schon anderthalb Jahre bei ihr gelebt
und vor einem halben Jahr wollte ich den
Hamster schon mal mitnehmen aber dann
wollten die Kinder ihn doch irgendwie
haben weil typisch Kinder die wünschen
sich ein Tier und dann holt man ihn das
Tier und dann können sie sich irgendwie
te doch nicht darum kümmern oder ist ist
zu viel oder sie sind zu faul keine
Ahnung und dann habe ich gesagt ich
nehme ihn gerne dann hatten sie sich
aber doch um entschieden und wollten ihn
doch behalten dann war ich ein bisschen
traurig und dann hat sie mir zum
Geburtstag mitgebracht da haben die
Kinder gesagt ja okay komm soll sie ih
nehmen und ich bin sehr glücklich ich
könnte nicht glücklicher sein und der
Hamster kam in einem Käfig der auch
schon sehr groß war für normale
Verhältnisse was so in den Futterhäusern
und sowas verkauft wird weil das ist ja
teilweise diese kleinen Plastikteile
sind ja wirklich nicht artgerecht und
das was meine Schwester da hatte war
schon sehr groß ich wollte aber
natürlich alles noch größer haben weil
ich Hamster Videos gesehen habe und mir
genauso ein Gehege vorgestellt habe ja
und dann habe ich das von rudipad
genommen das ist das Laola Gehege und
ich könnte nicht glücklicher sein ich
bin das ist so ein super einfaches
Stecksystem von Werkhaus also so ein
patentiertes Stecksystem mit dem ich
diesen mit dem ich dieses Gehege
zusammengesteckt habe und ja was kann
man noch dazu sagen mega cool ich muss
es noch auf Instagram posten ich hatte
so viel zu tun die letzten Wochen und
ich wollte es auch erstmal testen weil
ich habe das zugeschickt gekriegt ich
hatte da angefragt ob ich ob ich einen
zugeschickt kriegen kann und natürlich
dann halt auch poste wenn es mir gefällt
und ich wollte es jetzt erstmal ein paar
Wochen ausprobieren und gucken ob mir
der wirklich gefällt und ja ist super da
drunter gibt's noch die Kommode die
passende die man dazu bestellen kann ja
und jetzt habe ich einfach so eine fette
hamstervilla hier stehen aber ich liebe
ich liebe mein Hamster ah da bewegt er
sich
da man sieht ih oh da ist er dieser
Hamster den ihr jetzt nicht seht heißt
Hassan Wolke braunisch Hassan weil wir
einfach den Namen gut finden Hassan also
das den habe ich mit Anni zusammen
überlegt meine Managerin Wolke weil er
aussieht wie eine Wolke weil das ein
Teddy Hamster ist und der super viele
Fell und so ganz flauschig aussieht und
braunisch weil er natürlich auch zur
Familie gehört und er den Namen meines
Verlobten annimmt braunisch Hass Wolke
braunisch so setzt sich Name zusammen
ist doch ganz normal und weil wir jetzt
wegfahren machen wir den jetzt natürlich
noch einmal sauber und wenn wir dann weg
sind kümmert sich anni um ihn also sie
kommt dann hier her so ein Hamster ist
ja zum Glück kann man ja auch alle zwei
Tage kommen Wasser noch mal umtauschen
Futter noch mal umtauschen und so das
das ist schon alles easy machbar das
jetzt nicht wie ein Hund oder eine Katze
ja das ist es halt viel schwieriger wenn
man dann wegfahren möchte deswegen ist
no ein Hamster eigentlich cooles
Haustier das einzige Manko finde ich
wirklich dass man ihn halt nicht oft
sieht ich störe ihn auch halt kaum ich
nehme ihn jetzt nicht oft auf die Hand
äh nur wenn ich wirklich merke dass er
wach aktiv und entspannt ist so dass er
Bock hat auch mal auf meine Hand zu
gehen oder ich ihn mal so durchkämme mit
dem Fell aber ansonsten lass ich ihn
Schillen ich beobachte ihn da er hat
sein kleines Loch ich kann da reingucken
und das reicht mir eigentlich auch schon
und ja ist ein Haustier ein sehr
passives Haustier würde ich sagen du
findest langweilig ne boring und ein
klarer Vorteil bei so einem großen
Gehege ist du musst da nicht viel sauber
machen der macht alles eigentlich
relativ in einer Ecke also der hat da
seine Pipiecke der äh macht
seine Knödel macht er in sein in seinen
Unterschlupf da rein die hamsterlosung
die ist nicht ähm unhygienisch oder so
das ist jetzt nicht ähm also das kann
ruhig sich anhäufen und irgendwann macht
man das dann weg es ist nicht wie bei
anderen Tieren das ist eigentlich sein
ursprüngliches Häuschen und man kann
sehen hier unten hat er sich
reingegraben und von da kommt er auch
runter und eigentlich benutzt er nur den
unteren Teil den oberen Teil benutzt er
hier aber als Toilette hier
weiß ich nicht als Durchgang ja das ist
eigentlich seine Toilette dann habe ich
jetzt hier mein designated Mülleimer und
dann gehe ich hier mit einem
handelsüblichen Esslöffel und greif mir
da das oberste Zeug das ist mit Pipi da
habe ich dann unten bisschen Sand oben
Streu und dann muss ich das da nur
wegnehmen und dann ist es das das mache
ich so alle drei Tage ach guck und wer
meldet sich da wir hab nicht gesehen auf
Kamera soll ich ih warte mal ich gebe
ihm was dann kannst
[Musik]
du nicht die habe ich übrigens selbst
getrocknet ich habe ein D Automaten aber
eigentlich jetzt hat sich schon viel
angesammelt jetzt machen wir doch einmal
auf
upsi das ist ja fies ah guck mal ja
sieht schon viel besser aus mit seinem
Auge nicht wundern Leute der hat gerade
irgendwie seit di Tagen was mit dem Auge
gehabt aber es wird gerade wieder besser
also spar euch die Kommentare ich habe
das mit dem Auge im Blick wir haben das
schon mit einem feuchten Wattestäbchen
bisschen frei gemacht aber es wird
gerade wieder besser und nicht schlimmer
also einen Tag lang hat er das Auge so
ein bisschen zugehabt und jetzt ist es
aber viel besser schon geworden und
Annie ist da und wir haben schon alles
vorbereitet mit Transportbox und so
falls das mit dem Auge schlimmer wird
geht sie auch mit ihm zum Tierarzt da
muss ich sagen das finde ich schon krass
mit so einem Tier weil wir jetzt ja
wegfahren was da eigentlich dann auf so
für Stress mit drin steckt der denkt
sich auch so kannst du mal der geht
immer dahin wo ich na
komm geh do mal geh do mal weiter will
nur so ein bisschen Knödel mitnehmen
super klasse wir sind gutes Team
Hass na natürlich also natürlich besser
ist am Tag zum am Abend zu machen wenn
er schon eh wach ist aber ich muss sagen
seit er dieses große Gehege hat ist echt
nicht viel draußen also so dass wir es
mitbekommen eher nachts wenn wir
schlafen jetzt fülle ich ein bisschen
Sand in seiner Toilette nach immer so
viel wie ich rausgenommen habe das ist
Chinchilla Sand und dann kommt da noch
eine gute Hand streuum drauf das ist
auch eine tolle experience für ih ist
pass gut auf Dich auf grüß Annie wenn du
sie siehst und HDF HDF halt deine Fresse
fun
HF und halt deine Fresse h okay wir
gucken jetzt noch ein Auflauf das für
ein geiles we
oh hör mir auf
Timo auf Kisch angelehnt
ne wollt ihr mich verarschen ist das
nicht also wirklich guck mal wie gut das
sieht richtig gut aus ne ist richtig
geil geworden also auch diese schöne
dunkle Oberfläche hier und jetzt gehen
wir einfach mal rein und probieren das
das kriegt man wenn man Reste essen
macht ja ist lecker echt mega lecker
geil schmeckt wie wie beim Spanier ich
habe jetzt sogar noch hot Salz Soße
gefunden die ich mal für tortias geholt
habe also für tortier Chips und jetzt
essen wir eine tortier und ich kann mir
aber vorstellen dass die Tora dazu auch
gut passt ich wollte eigentlich Ketchup
dazu essen aber wir haben kein
Ketchup passt richtig aus Versehen
einfach was richtig leckeres gekocht so
ich habe noch überlegt ob ich das zeigen
muss aber wir müssen heute noch packen
das ist das Letzte was wir heute noch
erledigen müssen alles packen für 10
Tage wir müssen für ganz kalt packen wir
müssen für mittelwarm packen vielleicht
noch was zum Sport machen zum Schwimmen
wir haben in dem einen Hotel habe ich
gehört haben wir sogar Pool morgen um 13
Uhr geht dann unser Flieger und dann
sind wir morgen einfach schon in Mailand
das erste Mal in
Italien ja in einer Stunde geht es für
uns zum Flughafen wir sind fast fertig
gepackt eine Sache fehlt noch ich würde
fast sagen die
wichtigste meine
eigene Kerze ich habe den Duft
ausgesucht der Fantas riecht bisschen
wie frisch gewaschen Kopfnote wür ich
spontan sagen Himbeere orange Eukalyptus
frühstüft Akkord die
Herznote rote johannesbeere wilder
Salbei Zucker fallallchen und die basisn
ist sicher patuli indisches Sandelholz
Kokosnussschale od Vanillezucker also
einfach ein toller Duft für den Winter
die Kerze heißt auch malwanne im
Winter und das Design zieht euch das mal
selber gemacht gell habe ich selber
gemalt auch das hier oben hier ist auch
noch so ein Sticker habe ich auch hab
ich habe ich selber
Design das ist also eine große schneef
also sieht toll aus ich lieb es ne
findest es auch gut oder ja und falls
ihr auch so eine Kerze haben wollt dann
findet ihr unten in der Infobox den Link
dort könnt ihr eine bestellen die Kerzen
sind aus 100% sojax und 100% headmade in
Deutschland und das war's dann auch wir
fahren jetzt nach Mailand Leute bis
morgen tschüss